[Music]
Teen Mom og star Tyler Baltierra
continues to make major lifestyle
changes I don't want to focus anymore
the MTV star has been documenting his
weight-loss journey on social media this
time with a shirtless snapchat pic over
the weekend Tyler showed off his slimmer
figure while posing in the mirror
captioned feels so damn good reaching
this weight loss goal hashtag tool pick
the 26 year old star has been keeping
his followers up to date on all his
progress here's Tyler eight weeks into
his journey 35 pounds lighter and with a
more chiseled jawline in the caption he
also celebrated quitting smoking
cigarettes over two years ago while
Tyler is looking healthier on the
outside he is also making strides to
improve his mental health by attending
therapy a little self-care today and I
mean sometimes got to put yourself ahead
of some other people sometimes in life
but doesn't be you don't love them or
care about just means you love them
enough to put yourself first
[Music]